we tend to be generous towards people
who can't get over someone it sounds
romantic
if a little sad the love affair happened
a year ago but still the exes thoughts
remain loyal to every detail of the
story maybe they've moved to another
country perhaps they've married someone
else
maybe they're dead none of it matters
the most famous fictional love affair of
the 18th century
Goethe's sorrows of young Verta is a
hugely sympathetic study of this kind of
romantic fixation the hero Vetter an
ardent young student falls passionately
in love with a charming and beautiful
woman named Charlotte she likes him but
doesn't love him back in part because
she's married to someone else there are
plenty of other nice women who single
attractive and interested invertor but
he has no time for them the only one he
cares for is Charlotte the one who
doesn't care for him eventually unable
to have Charlotte's love Berta decides
to kill himself the novel proved hugely
charming to its original audiences who
praised it for its deep and pure
understanding of love this sort of
unrequited passion so often celebrated
in literature and society more generally
may sound generous and in that sense
loving but a devotion to an unrequited
situation is in truth a clever way of
ensuring that we won't end up in a
relationship at all that we won't ever
need to suffer the realities of love
fixation on an absent other allows us to
be publicly committed to love while
privately sheltered from any of its more
arduous demands the fear of love may be
motivated by a range of factors a
squeamishness around hope a self-hatred
which makes someone else's love feel
eerie or a fear of self-revelation
which breeds a reluctance to let anyone
into the secret parts of ourselves the
fears are serious and deserve sympathy
but they are generally not the issues
that the romantically fixated person
ever wants to discuss they prefer to
keep the spotlight on the unresponsive
ex rather than on their motives for
continuing to dwell on them the way to
unfix 8 is not to tell ourselves that we
never liked a person it's to get very
serious and specific about what the
attraction was based on and then to come
to see that the qualities we admired in
the ex must necessarily exist in other
people who don't have the set of
problems that made the original
relationship impossible the careful
investigation of the character of one
person paradoxically but very liberating
ly shows that we could in fact also love
someone else this is not an exercise in
getting us to give up on what we really
want the liberating move is to see that
what we want has to exist in places
beyond the pain inducing character we
originally identified it in we should
gently recognize that being disappointed
and abandoned has it's curious
satisfactions it is in an emotional
sense a very safe position to be in
indeed yet true love isn't to be equated
with pining for an absent figure it
means daring to engage with a truly
frightening prospect a person who is
available and thinks despite our strong
background suppositions to the contrary
that we're really rather nice that is
perhaps the only sort of challenge that
properly deserves the lyrical and grand
word romantic
you